welcome to another episode of cradle -
grab your authority on the baddest
fastest craft cycles on the planet
I'm your host roamers shorter the title
for toughest grav cycle gang around
comes down to these nine contenders the
deadly assembly of mercenaries assassins
and Psychopaths
here's the breakdown
neon dreams you like pastels a 1980
synth rock well that's not the bassline
that's splitting your ear sensors it's a
slug from a light machine gun there's a
rhythm to the way neon dreams dismantle
their opponents and while all that speed
comes at the cost of armor they are not
losing sleep over
in a time it takes you to line up a shot
they're already behind you again with a
fresh magazine
Kingsguard don't let the fantasy
aesthetic for you these medieval
badasses can dish out the pain just as
well as they can take you with armor
thick as the day is long
and a javelin launcher that hits like a
ballista the Kingsguard earns their keep
at the front line of any assault hard to
make them flinch and they'll be
impossible to take down sideshows these
circus freaks have more than a few gags
up their sleeves if you consider
remote-detonated sticky grenades gags
the sideshows MO is deception and
misdirection trap wound chip as if I
didn't already hate clowns another tech
new walk worshippers of design at the
razor's edge from their clothes to their
tech to their weapons Tech war thrives
by fighting in maneuvering from the
outside while their squad mates get up
close and personal to handle the dirty
work but that doesn't mean they can't
reach out and touch someone with a shot
from their ng6 marksman camp
warheads if the name didn't tip you all
they specialize in making things go boom
take for example trainings you thought
one grenade was enough you just didn't
have the vision to realize what true
unbridled carnage looks like and then
there's the warhead when you absolutely
positively need to eviscerate every
living atom in the room set no subsidy
lost roni disciplined warriors that make
all-out offense look like poetry in
motion
lethal at any distance once this crew
sets its sight on you the most you can
hope for is an honorable death though
I'm not sure how honored I would feel
being ripped apart by a barrage of human
sockets the business mayhem is money and
when this crew takes the battlefield
let's just say they make it random no
fancy gadgets to master here just good
old-fashioned assault rifles and
shotguns because when it comes to
getting results sometimes the old ways
are still the best works we're toast
looking for a dance with death look no
further
these nimble and aggressive assassins
will gladly send you to the afterlife
with a pair of semi automatic shotguns
if that doesn't finish the job their
centuries can handle the cleanup
some consolation you won't have to worry
about dying alone
finally the militia their motto
ain't no problem a bullet can't soft
stroll into their crosshairs and you'll
catch some heat from their autocannons
loaded with explosive rise when the clip
runs dry guess what more guts after all
in the North American DMZ and most cheap
so that's the tale of the tape you come
face-to-face with any of these crews you
better be settled up on a graph cycle
with a solid team backing you up
otherwise you can kiss that brain can
goodbye I've been your host Rovers all
and this has been cradle to graff until
next time keep your gears clean and your
powder dry
you